Tại sao tài như trời hả tính nhật được bà miệng chủ đồng, tìm trả lại người để dưới.
Phó sáng ngày May 3, anh nguyễn trong thế, sinh 1,5 hình chân tạm mít tư ở thế chẳng lột ha,
đến công an tị chẳng lột ha sau lột bú chức biến, bên trong vi có hai thẻ cân cứ công dân,
một thẻ a tiêm và số tiêm bà miệng chủ đồng.
Đây là tài sản anh tị nhật được vào tối như mì sảo tháng mười là mạnh an công trong hàng mít tư,
tại khu bực máy tham sơn hành.
Sất ký tích nhận công an tị chẳng lột ha,
kế nảy sất mình, sất định chủ tài khoảng nơi trên là ông Leigh Bà Thần,
chủ tại thuật sáo, sắp biến an, Việt lực ha, chưa công ngay,
công an tị chẳng cũng ngánh tện, đã tính anh bà rao lại vi,
sẽ tà vào số tiêm bà vi bà vi bà chủ đồng cho ông Leigh Bà Thần,
đây là hành động, này tính nhìn vào nguang tệ đảm đứa bử dương.